>>> YOU JUST TAPPED INTO THE
GROUP CHAT LIVE PRESENTED BY FAN
DUEL BUT IT'S LIVE ON "THE
BLEACHER REPORT."
I ALMOST FUMBLED THERE,  LeBRON
SITUATION, BUT IN TERMS OF THE
LeBRON SITUATION SINCE EVERYONE
IS TALKING ABOUT IT, YOU AND I
KIND OF DEBATED AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE SHOW OR I SHOULD SAY
BEFORE THE SHOW WAS IT A CLOSED
FIST OR AN ELBOW?
EVERY ANGLE LOOKS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT.
SOME ANGLES LOOK LIKE IT'S AN
ACCIDENT.
SOME ANGLES LOOK LIKE IT'S
TOTALLY INTENTIONAL.
>> YEAH.
>> SO NOBODY KNOWS THE REAL
ANSWER BUT LeBRON JAMES AND,
UNFORTUNATELY HE COULDN'T MAKE
IT FOR TODAY'S SHOW SO --
>> UNFORTUNATELY, LeBRON
COULDN'T MAKE IT.
WE DON'T -- WE DO WANT TO KNOW.
YOU GUYS COMMENT.
WAS IT AN ELBOW OR A CLOSED FIST
YOU?
GUYS LET US KNOW IN THE COMMENT.
ERIN, I HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION.
THANKSGIVING IS COMING UP.
BETTOR SIDE ON THANKSGIVING, MAC
AND CHEESE OR STUFFING?
>> I'M GOING TO SAY NEITHER.
I THINK THAT WE SHOULD NORMALIZE
NORMAL FOOD FOR THANKSGIVING
BECAUSE THERE'S A REASON WHY WE
ONLY EAT THESE FOODS ON
THANKSGIVING.
IT'S BECAUSE YOU ONLY WANT IT
ONCE A YEAR.
IT'S NOT TASTY.
IT IS REALLY NOT THAT DELICIOUS.
TURKEY IS THE LAST MEAT I WOULD
CHOOSE TO EAT.
I TOLD MY MOM WHO IS MAKING
DINNER TO MAKE SWEET POTATOES OR
SOMETHING THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT BUT FOR ME I DON'T EAT
EITHER OF THOSE THINGS.
HOW ABOUT YOU?
>> ERIN, I'M TAKING THE MAC AND
CHEESE FOR SURE.
STUFFING, I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
IS, BUT I KNOW WHAT DRESSING IS.
MY MOM MAKES A MEAN DRESSING SO
I'M TAKING BOTH OF THOSE AND I'M
THANKFUL FOR BOTH OF THOSE.
>> WAIT, YOU NEED TO TELL --
WHAT IS DRESSING?
WHAT'S DRESSING?
>> PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE,
PEOPLE THAT KNOW WHAT DRESSING
IS, YOU GUYS LET US KNOW WHAT
DRESSING IS IN THE COMMENTS.
LET ERIN KNOW -- IT'S SIMILAR TO
STUFFING.
IT'S JUST COOKED OR -- IT'S A
LITTLE DIFFERENT.
A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
ANYWAYS.
>> I DON'T EAT IT ANYWAYS SO
IT'S NEITHER HERE NOR THERE.
>> ERIN, WE'VE GOT -- WE
PROBABLY GOT TO INVITE TO YOU AN
IVORY THANKSGIVING FEAST TO GET
YOU ALL THIS FLAVORFUL,
FLAVORFUL FOOD.
BUT AS ALWAYS WE'RE GIVING AWAY
LOCKS, WE'RE GIVING AWAY HOODIES
AND JERSEYS SO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND MAKE SURE YOU GUYS
GET IN THE COMMENTS, AND I NEED
GIFTS.
I NEED EMOJIS BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY I NEED WINNERS ONLY,
PLEASE.
ERIN, ARE YOU READY TO GET AND
HOP INTO IT?
ARE YOU READY TO HOP INTO IT?
>> LET'S GET INTO IT.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT TODAY, IS
RIGHT?
YOU KNOW WHAT TODAY IS, RIGHT?
TODAY IS TNT TUESDAYS.
THAT MEANS FAN DUEL IS BOOSTING
THE THREE BY TWO IN BOTH GAMES.
MAKING IT THREE BY TUESDAY.
THE QUESTION IS WILL THERE BE
TWO THREE-POINTERS IN THE FIRST
THREE MINUTES OF TONIGHT'S GAME?
LAST WEEK THE THREE BY TWO
CASHED WITH THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS TAKING ON THE NETS.
LET'S ACTUALLY TAKE A LOOK AT
THE HIGHLIGHTS.
>> THEY HAVE GOT A WEEK LONG --
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
HIGHLIGHT AND I'LL WALK YOU GUYS
THROUGH IT.
THE FIRST ONE WAS PATTY MILLS,
AND THEN YOU GUYS
>> THERE'S YOUR BOY.
>> STEPH CURRY.
THAT'S 30.
HE DOES WHAT HE DOES.
>> YES.
DEFINITELY ONE OF MY FAVORITE
PEOPLE.
30 DOES WHAT HE DOES, AND THE
THREE BY TWO CARE, BUT TODAY WE
ASKED YOU ON TWITTER WHICH THREE
BY TWO WILL CASH TONIGHT?
WE HAVE THE LAKERS TAKING ON THE
KNICKS AND WE HAVE THE NUGGETS
TAKING ON THE BLAZERS, AND HERE
ARE THE RESULTS.
>> I'M KIND OF SURPRISED.
>> OH, WOULD YOU, ERIN.
>> TELL US WHY.
>> I'M A LITTLE SURPRISED.
>> THEY BOTH HAVE SHOOTERS.
>> THEY DO, YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> DENVER AND PORTLAND -- DENVER
AND PORTLAND THEY HAVE SHOOTERS,
DANE, YOU KNOW, C.J.
MICHAEL PORTER.
THEY HAVE GUYS THAT ARE MORE
THAN CAPABLE OF MAKING TWO
THREE-POINTERS IN THE FIRST
THREE MINUTES SO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND YOU LET ME KNOW
WHICH THREE BY TWO IS A LOCK.
ERIN, WHICH ONE DO YOU LIKE
BETTER?
>> JUST A REMINDER, YOU CAN BET
ON BOTH OF THEM BUT I'M GOING
WITH THE LAKERS/KNICKS.
I THINK THE KNICKS CAN SCORE
BOTH -- TWO OF THE
THREE-POINTERS IN THE FIRST
THREE MONTHS.
YOU HAVE QUACKER, EVAN FOURNIER
AND JULIUS RANDLE.
THEY WILL BE AT HOME AT THE
GARDEN.
I'M TAKING THAT FIRST GAME FOR
THE THREE BY TWO TO CASH.
>> ERIN IS ROCKING THE FIRST
GAME.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS AND
SEE WHAT YOU GUYS ARE ROCKING
WITH IN THE COMMENTS.
I'VE GOT -- I'VE GOT AK-47 BIG
BLUE SAYS BOTH.
HE'S ROCKING WITH BOTH OF THEM.
I'VE GOT GAF INC. 2,
NUGGETS/BLAZERS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
DAME IS HITTING BOTH.
DAME IS HITTING BOTH SHOTS.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
WESTBROOK 34 SIS WESTBROOK IS
GOING TO MAKE UP OF THOSE
THREES, NO LIE AND THE KNICKS
MAY GET THE REST.
SHOUT-OUT TO EVERYBODY.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
ERIN, I'M GOING TO RIDE WITH THE
PEOPLE HERE.
THE THREE BY TWO THAT WE'RE
RIDE, UNFORTUNATELY, IS NOT THE
LOS ANGELES LAKERS VERSUS THE
KNICKS, BUT I LOVE YOUR PLAY,
ERIN, AN ARE I HOPE THAT YOU
WIN, BUT WE ARE RIDING THE
DENVER NUGGETS VERSUS THE
PORTLAND TRAIL BLAZERS.
LET'S GO DAME.
HIT BOTH OF THEM, WHY NOT, BUT
WE ARE RIDING THAT THREE BY TWO.
LET'S MOVE ON.
LET'S TALK ABOUT MY GYRUS EL
WESTBROOK.
WE ASKED YOU IN THE APP HOW MANY
POINTS WILL RUSSELL SCORE
TONIGHT?
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND LET US
KNOW.
TELL US WHAT YOU THINK.
AT THE END OF THE GAME WE'LL DM
ONE RANDOM PERSON WHO GETS
CLOESTS AND HOOK YOU UP WITH A
JERSEY.
ERIN, THE LINE IS CURRENTLY AT
19.5.
LeBRON IS OUT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> SO, WESTBROOK HAD 26 POINTS
LAST GAME SCORING 15 OF 26 IN
THAT FOURTH QUARTER TO REAL
AGAINST THE PIVOT OVNLS OF
COURSE, LeBRON JAMES WAS TAKEN
OUT OF THAT GAME SO SOME MAY BE
THINKING KIND OF LIKE YOU ARE
THAT LeBRON IS OUT AND MAYBE
RUSSELL WESTBROOK IS GOING TO GO
OFF AND WHEN JAMES WAS OFF EIGHT
GAMES DUE TO THE BE A NOMINAL
STRAIN RUSSELL AVERAGED 19
POINTS.
I'M STILL GOING TO GO WITH THE
UNDER HERE, NOT A POPULAR PLAY
GIVEN THAT THE KNICKS DEFENSE IS
ALLOWING 42 POINTS IN THE PAINT
BETTER THAN MAJORITY OF THE TEAM
IN THE LEAGUES SO I'M ROCKING
WITH THE UNDER FOR HIS POINTS.
>> ERIN.
I LOVE THE PLAY.
LOVE THE PLAY, BUT I'M GOING THE
OTHER WAY SIMPLY BECAUSE, WE'RE
JUST GOING TO DO SIMPLE -- WE'RE
GOING ADD IT UP SIMPLY LIKE
THIS.
RUSSELL WESTBROOK IS GOING TO
NEW YORK.
RUSSELL WESTBROOK IS PLAYING AT
MADISON SQUARE GARDEN.
THEREFORE, RUSSELL WESTBROOK
WILL TRY TO PUT ON A SHOW.
NO LeBRON JAMES.
HE'S GOING TO BE TRY TO ROCK
SOME BABIES AND GOING TO TRY TO
ROCK SOME RIMS.
HE'LL BE THROWING PASSES.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S GOING TO DO.
WE KNOW THAT RUSS IS JUST GOING
TO TRY TO SHOW UP AT MADISON
SQUARE GARDEN, SO I'VE GOT TO
ROCK WITH THE OVER HERE AND I
HAVE TO ROCK WITH THE OVER.
>> THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
IT'S GOT WHAT I THINK.
IT'S ABOUT WHAT THE PEOPLE THINK
AND I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT
NOW.
THIS IS THE HANDY DANDY THING
FOR PEOPLE THAT DO NOT KNOW.
I'VE GOT J. JOHNSON SAYING --
I'M SEEING A LOT OF 29.
D.JOHNSON 396 SAYS 23.
HE'S ROCKING WITH THE OVER.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, D. JOHNSON.
RONALD SAYS HE'LL SCORE 27.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
G. QUINN 26 SAYS WOW, UPPED.
I'M SHOCKED.
HE'S SHOCKED BY YOUR UNDER.
IT IS OKAY.
REMEMBER AFTER THE GAME WE'RE
GOING TO HIT UP ONE PERSON.
>> YEAH.
YOU KNOW YOU GOT LOVE IN THE
COMMENTS THERE.
THEY LOVE YOU IN THE COMMENT.
>> ONE SOLDIER IN THERE.
>> YEAH.
WE DON'T HAVE TO QUESTION -- WE
DON'T HAVE TO QUESTION WHETHER
THEY LOVE YOU IN THE COMMENTS.
WE KNOW THAT THEY LOVE YOU IN
THE COMMENTS, ERIN, BUT I WANT
THE PEOPLE TO REMEMBER AFTER THE
GAME WE'RE GOING TO HIT UP ONE
PERSON AND HOOK YOU UP WITH A
JERSEY.
ERIN, LET'S MOVE ON TO YOUR
FAVORITE PART OF THE SHOW.
LET'S TALK MAJOR MARKETS, MONEY
LINES AGAINST THE SPREAD AND
POINT TOTALS FOR TONIGHT'S GAME.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS.
ERIN, WHAT ARE YOU SEEING HERE,
AND WHAT DO YOU LIKE?
>> SO I'M GOING TO GO OVER 215
IN THE NUGGETS VERSUS PORTLAND
GAME.
THE OVER OF 7-1 IN THE LAST
EIGHT MEETINGS.
THE LAST EIGHT MEETINGS BETWEEN
THE TEAMS, ON NOVEMBER 14th,
OVER 215 DID HIT IF THAT WAS THE
TOTAL SET FOR THE GAME.
THE DENVER NUGGETS ACTUALLY WON
THAT GAME 124-59 AND DAMIAN
LILLARD DID NOT PLAY IN THAT
GAME WITH AN ABDOMINAL INJURY.
THIS TIME ENJOKIC WAITING TO SEE
ON HIS STATUS, STILL
QUESTIONABLE.
I'M STILL GOING TO GO WITH THE
OVER ON THIS GAME.
DAMIAN LILLARD OUT OF THE
SHOOTING SLUMP SO I THINK THESE
TEAMS CAN GO OFF.
>> I LOVE THAT, ERIN.
I LOVE THAT, ERIN.
I'M ACTUALLY GOING TO RIDE WITH
YOU ON THAT OVER.
I LOOKED UP A STAT IN PORTLAND
IN THE LAST THREE GAMES WENT
OVER THIS TOTAL IN THE LAST
THREE GAMES SO I THINK THAT
TREND IS GOING TO CONTINUE.
>> OKAY.
>> I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO BE
HOT.
YOU MENTIONED DAME.
YOU KNOW THE OFFENSIVE FIREPOWER
THAT THEY HAVE IN PORTLAND BUT
NOT ONLY DO THEY HAVE OFFENSIVE
FIREPOWER IN PORTLAND SO DOES
DENVER SO I'M RIDING WITH YOU
WITH THE OVER.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS, AND I WANT
TO SEE WHAT THEY ARE RIDING
WITH.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS GIVING AWAY
HOODIES.
YEAH.
THEY ARE SAYING IT'S ALL OF G.
QUINN SAYING IT'S ALL LOVE HERE,
ERIN.
IT IS ALL LOVE.
I HAVE -- I HAVE YOUNG GRAVY 56
SAYS TRAIL BLAZERS DAME WILL
DROP 60 TONIGHT.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU AND --
>> THAT'S BIG NUMBERS.
>> SUPER BAD.
>> SUPER BAD SAYS NASIR LITTLE
GETS 15 POINTS OFF THE BENCH.
HE SAYS LET'S GO, BLAZERS, SO I
THIN HE'S TAKING THE BLAZERS
MONEY LINE SAND SPRING LYNN IN A
BET FOR US.
NASIR LITTLE, SHOUT-OUT TO
EVERYBODY THAT I JUST MENTIONED.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
ERIN, LET'S MOVE ON.
WE TALKED MAJOR MARKETS AND NOW
LET'S TALK PLAYER PROPS.
WE'RE GOING TO TALK A LITTLE
GAME LOCK OR NOT.
I'M GOING TO PUT UP A PROP.
I'M GOING TO PUT UP A PROP AND
YOU GUYS GET IN THE COMMENTS AND
TELL ME WHETHER IT'S A LOOK OR
IT'S NOT.
ERIN, ARE YOU READY?
>> YES.
LET'S DO IT.
>> LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
FIRST UP IS DAME TO SCORE OVER
24 1/2 POINTS IN TONIGHT'S
DENVER/PORTLAND MATCHUP.
THE ODDS ARE AT -- THE ODDS ARE
AT MINUS 106, ERIN, FOR THE
OVER.
IS THAT A LOCK OR IS IT NOT?
>> THAT IS A LOOK.
DAME HAS FOUND HIS STRIDE.
26 POINTS.
AVERAGING THE LAST SEVEN
CONSECUTIVE GAMES.
ACTUALLY INCREASING HIS SHOOTING
PERCENTAGE WHICH IS UP TO 39%
WHICH IS STILL RELATIVELY SUB
PAR COMPARED TO HIS PREVIOUS
SEASONS BUT I THINK HE'S OUT OF
THE SHOOTING SLUMP.
WE'RE SEEING THINGS TRENDING
UPWARD FOR HIM SO I'M DEFINITELY
GOING TO TAKE THE OVER FOR THIS
GAME.
>> I LOVE THAT.
I LOVE THAT TAKE, ERIN.
THIS IS SURPRISING.
I KNOW DAME HAS BEEN STRUGGLING
BUT 24.5 POINTS.
DAMIAN LILLARD?
I'M ROCKING RIGHT THERE.
WE'RE SENDING THE GOOD VIBES,
ERIN FROM PHILADELPHIA AND ME
FROM THE BAY.
GO AND GET THAT OVER.
WE'RE RIDING WITH YOU.
NEXT UP IS PAUL GEORGE.
ACTUALLY BEFORE I MOVE ON,
BEFORE I MOVE ON, LET ME HOP
INTO THE COMMENTS BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE ARE HERE FOR HOODIES.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS, AND I'VE
GOT BAD SPORTS TAKE SAYS LOCK
ALL DAY.
DAME IS ABOUT TO GO OFF.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
RICH BARTEL IS IN THE COMMENTS
SAYING THAT'S A LOCK, BABY.
SHOUT-OUT TO BOAST YOU GUYS.
BOTH OF YOU GUYS ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH HOODIES.
NEXT IS UP PAUL GEORGE SITTING
AT 25 POINTS, ERIN.
IS THE OVER A LOCK OR NOT?
>> SO THESE TWO TEAMS ACTUALLY
JUST MET WITH THE CLIPPERS
WINNING BY SIX POINTS.
PAUL GEORGE POSTED 29 POINTS IN
THAT WIN, SO THE OVER, IT'S A
LOCK FOR THIS ONE AS WELL.
>> ERIN IS ROCKING WITH THE
OVER.
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO FOUL, ERIN.
I'M GOING HAVE TO FOLLOW YOU.
YOU MENTIONED HE JUST SCORED 29.
HE AVERAGES 26.
SITTING AT 25.5.
P.G., GO GET 26, BRO.
GO GET 26.
YOU SHOULD BE -- YOU'RE WALKING
BUCKET.
P.G. IS DEFINITELY UNDER --
>> HE'S BEEN AWESOME THIS
SEASON.
>> JUST A WALKING BUCKET SO JUST
GO GET 26.
>> YES, HE HAS.
HE HAS BEEN REALLY GOOD THIS
SEASON.
NO KAWHI SO HE'S THE GUY IN LOS
ANGELES.
LET'S MOVE ON, ERIN.
LET'S MOVE ONLY.
ACTUALLY, BEFORE WE MOVE ON,
I'VE GOT TO TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
I'VE GOT TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
I'VE GOT TO -- I'VE GOT TO -- I
JUST NEED SOME VIBE FROM THE
PEOPLE.
I NEED SOME VIBES.
>> SEND GOOD VIBES.
>> I'VE GOT M. GO BLUE SAYS NO.
NO, THAT PAUL GEORGE IS NOT
GOING TO GO OVER.
I WONDER WHY.
RON OCUNA IS BACK GIVING HIS
TAKES.
GAVE US TWO LOCKS IN A ROW, TWO
WEEKS IN A ROW.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU AND I HAVE
MAXELL REXEL SAYING OVER SO
SHOUT-OUT TO EVERYBODY THAT I
MENTIONED.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
LET'S GO TO REGGIE JACKSON.
LET'S PULL THAT BACK UP, CONTROL
ROOM.
HE'S SITTING AT 17.5 POINTS,
ERIN.
17.5 POINTS.
IS THE OVER A LOCK OR NOT ON
THIS ONE?
>> IN TERMS OF HIS POINTS I FEEL
LIKE YOU HAVE TO GO WITH THE
LOCK TOWARDS THE OVER.
AT THIS POINT I JUST TOOK THREE
OVERS, SO I JUST THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE A GREAT NIGHT ALL
AROUND FOR ALL OF THESE TEAMS.
DEFINITELY GOING TO TAKE THE
OVER FOR HIM AS WELL.
>> ERIN IS TAKING THE OVER ON MY
GUY REG JACKSON, AND I RODE WITH
ERIN ON THE FIRST TWO.
WHY SWITCH UP?
WHY SWITCH UP THE VIBES?
REGGIE JACKSON, GO GET 18
POINTS, BROTHER.
TAKING ON THE MAVS.
I THINK HE CAN DO IT.
HE WAS A BUCKET IN THE PLAYOFFS
LAST YEAR.
THAT'S TRANSFERRING INTO THIS
SEASON.
>> YEAH.
>> REGGIE JACKSON, HE'S A BUCKET
DOWN THERE IN L.A.
BUT LET'S MOVE ON TO THIS LAST
SEGMENT BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW YOU
GUYS LOVE THE SAME GAME PARLAY,
SO B/R BETTING IS BUILDING OUR
OWN SAME GAME PARLAY AND GIVING
YOU GUYS AN OPPORTUNITY TO RIDE
WITH US, AND TONIGHT ON THE
"INSIDE THE NBA" PREGAME SHOW,
CHUCK, MY BOY CHARLES BARKLEY IS
GOING TO LOOK AT OUR PELE AND
PICK HIS FAVORITE LEG.
BEFORE I TELL YOU WHAT IT IS,
YOU GUYS GET IN THE COMMENTS AND
TELL ME WHAT YOU THINK OF THE
PARLAY, GRADE THE PARLAY AND
TELL ME WHICH LEGS IS GOING TO
HIT AND WHICH IS NOT GOING TO
HIT.
DISSECT PARLAY IN THE COMMENTS.
WE NEED VIBES, DEFINITELY NEED
VIBES.
THIS WEEK WE'RE TAKE LOOKING AT
THE LAKERS TAKING ON THE KNICKS.
NO LeBRON.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
WE'RE GOING TO START IT OFF WITH
MY GYRUS.
MY GYRUS, ERIN.
RUSSELL WESTBROOK TO SCORE 20
POINTS.
KNOW KNOW YOU WENT UNDER.
ERIN, DO YOU LIKE THIS LEG OF
THE PARLAY OR NOT?
>> WELL, I CAN'T SAY I LIKE THE
FIRST LEG OF THE PARLAY WHICH
JUST COMPLETELY RUINS THE REST
OF THE PARLAY BECAUSE I LIKE THE
UNDER AT 19.5 SO APPARENTLY
YOU'RE GOING AGAINST ME SO LET'S
SEE THE OTHER LEG.
IF WE HAVE POSITIVE VIBES FOR
THE OTHER ONE.
>> HOPEFULLY WE GET BETTER VIBES
FOR THE NEXT ONE.
ERIN, WE'RE GOING TO STAY WITH
RUSS.
WE'RE GOING TO STAY WITH RUSS.
WE KNOW HE LIKES TO DISH THE
BALL.
>> YES, YES.
>> SO ERIN, EIGHT-PLUS ASSISTS.
COME ON, NOW, I NEED GOOD VIBES.
RUSS TO GET EIGHT ASSISTS.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
WE'RE GETTING GOOD VIBES.
SHE SAYS THAT THAT'S EASY.
WE'RE LOCKED IN WITH THAT ONE.
LET'S MOVE ON.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ONE.
JULIUS RANDLE, JULIUS RANDLE.
>> OKAY.
>> THE OTHER 30, THE OTHER 30 IN
NEW YORK SITTING AT EIGHT PLUS
REBOUNDS.
ERIN, DO YOU THINK HE CAN GRAB
EIGHT FOR US TONIGHT?
>> I DO.
HE'S AVERAGING TEN REBOUNDS ON
THE SEASON, AND SO FAR THIS IS
MY FAVORITE LEG, SO WE'RE
GETTING MORE POSITIVE AS IT GOES
DOWN.
>> YES.
>> LET'S HEAR THE LAST LEG.
>> I LOST POSITIVE VIBES.
LOVE THE POSITIVE VIBES.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE LAST LEG,
ERIN.
WERE EVE GOT R.J. BERRY.
LET ME TAKE A DEEP BREATH ONE
MORE TIME.
R.J. BARRETT SITTING AT 15-PLUS
POINTS.
ERIN, I TOOK A DEEP BREATH.
I HAD TO TAKE A DEEP ONE THERE.
>> WHY DO YOU NEED A DEEP BREATH
FOR THIS ONE?
>> R.J. BARRETT.
IT'S R.J. BARRETT.
I MEAN --
>> 15 POINTS PER GAMES PER
SEASON SO IT CAN'T BE THAT BAD
OF A BET.
>> OKAY, OKAY.
ERIN IS SENDING ME GOOD VIBES.
SHE'S MAKING US FEEL GOOD.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
WELL, LET'S PULL UP THE TICKET
SO WE CAN SHOW THE PEOPLE AT
HOME.
>> WHAT?
>> IF THEY WERE TO PUT SOME
MONEY THON PARLAY.
>> IT'S A GOOD ONE.
>> YOU GUYS SEE IT.
YOU PUT 100 DOWN, YOU WALK AWAY
WITH 400, 400 AND SOME CHANGE.
ERIN, WE'RE GOING TO CALL THAT
400 AND SOME CHANGE.
>> THAT'S NOT CHUMP CHANGE.
>> IT'S 81.
>> ERIN, THAT'S SOME CHANGE.
THAT'S A DINNER AND A DRINK IN
VEGAS.
THAT'S SOME CHANGE.
>> THAT IS THE CHANGE IN VEGAS.
>> AND YOU GUYS CAN GET ON FAN
DUEL AND RIDE WITH US.
ERIN, BEFORE I GET INTO THE
COMMENTS, BEFORE I GET INTO THE
COMMENTS, I NEED YOU TO PUT ON
YOUR TEACHER'S HAT A LITTLE BIT
RIGHT HERE AND GRADE OUR SAME
GAME PARLAY.
WHAT GRADE DO YOU GIVE OUR SAME
GAME PARLAY?
>> I HAVE TO GIVE YOU A C-MINUS
BECAUSE WE STARTED OFF THE SHOW
WITH YOU ASKING ME RUSSELL
WESTBROOK'S POINT PROP, 19.5, I
SAID UNDER AND THEN YOU TAKE 20
PLUS AS THE FIRST LEG SO I CAN'T
GIVE YOU A GOOD GRADE JUST
CONSIDERING YOU COMPLETELY WENT
AGAINST YOUR CO-HOST SO WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO ROCK WITH A
C-MINUS.
>> A C-MINUS.
ERIN, YOU KNOW.
WHAT I LIKE TO TAKE THE POSITIVE
OUT OF THINGS, AND -- AND IN
COLLEGE Cs ACTUALLY LED ME TO MY
DEGREE SO, THEREFORE, Cs GET
DEGREES SO I'M GOING TO TAKE THE
C-MINUS.
TAKE IT WITH LOVE.
>> TAKE IT AND RUN WITH IT.
>> I'M TAKING IT AND RUNNING
WITH IT AND ACTUALLY I'M RUNNING
TO THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE IT'S TIME TO GIVE AWAY
AGERS, AND IT'S TIME TO GIVE
AWAY SOME HOODIES.
I WANT TO KNOW, LIKE, OKAY.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, INDERMINT FORE
ROCKING WITH US.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS, LOOKING
FOR A GOOD TAKE.
I SAY RCATLANO, THAT IS FOR THE
PRODUCERS.
HE SAYS TAKE BARRETT OFF THE
PARLAY.
GUESS WHAT I'M GOING TO DO FOR
THIS LUCKING COMMENTER.
I'M GOING TO GIVE THEM A JERSEY
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY SENT BAD
VIBES OUR WAY.
GUESS WHAT, WE DON'T RETURN --
WE DON'T RETURN BAD VIBES WITH
BAD VIBES.
WE TURN THE BAD VIBES INTO GOOD
VIBES.
>> EXACTLY.
>> SO RC.
>> SAYS YOU'RE A WALKING SUNSET.
>> I'M A WALKING SUNSET.
THE GUY THAT I JUST MENTIONED,
RCATALNO, THE PRODUCERS KNOW,
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
LET ME HOP IN HERE AND GIVE AWAY
SOME JERSEYS.
MARKED 1 SAYS THEY ARE ROCKING
WITH YOU.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE WITH
YOU WITH BUT THEY ARE WITH YOU
AND JUST BECAUSE THEY ARE WITH
YOU I'M GIVING THEM A HOODIE
McFLY.
McFLY SAYS RANDLE DOUBLE-DOUBLE
AND THE WIN.
LOVE THE TAKE.
I'M GIVING YOU A HEED AS WELL.
ERIN, LET'S MOVE -- OH,
ACTUALLY.
I WANT YOU TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS, ERIN.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND SPREAD
SOME LOVE.
>> OKAY.
>> I'VE BEEN SPREADING A LOT OF
LOVE.
I WANT YOU TO --
>> SOME OF THEM THAT I THINK
THAT YOU'VE MENTIONED.
SOMEBODY KEEPS PUTTING IN DWIGHT
SHOOT OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
MFLYDE, REGGIE 20 AND A WIN AND
A LOCK.
THANK YOU FOR BEING PART OF THE
CONVO.
APPRECIATE YOU AND YOU GET A
HOODIE.
>> THANKS FOR BEING PART OF THE
CONVO.
>> YOU CAUGHT ERIN'S EYE.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE IN HERE
SPAMMING.
>> THEY ARE SPAMMING BIG TIME IN
THE COMMENTS.
IT'S ALL LOVE THOUGH.
IT IS ALL LOVE.
ERIN, ARE YOU RED FOR THE NEXT
ONE?
BEFORE WE HOP INTO IT I'M GOING
TO LET YOU GUYS KNOW, I TOLD YOU
GUYS EARLIER IN THE YEAR, AND
I'M TELLING YOU AGAIN TO BET THE
WARRIORS TO WIN THE FINALS.
ERIN, THE WARRIORS ARE 15-2.
KLAY IS GOING BACK IN THE NEXT
AND THE NETS ARE STILL FAVORED
TO WIN IT ALL.
I NEED YOU AT HOME TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHO YOU
THINK SHOULD BE A FAVORITE TO
WINCH IT ALL.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT LATEST
ODDS, ERIN.
ODDS.
WARRIORS ARE CURRENTLY SECOND
FAVORITE AT PLUS 650.
ANOTHER DEEP BREATH RIGHT THERE,
ERIN.
SHOULD THE WARRIORS, SHOULD THEY
BE THE OVERALL FAVORITE?
SHOULD THEY BE THE OVERALL
FAVORITE?
>> AT THIS POINT I THINK THEY
SHOULD.
WE'RE ALMOST ONE-FOURTH INTO THE
SEASON.
THE WARRIORS AFTER WHAT WE HAVE
SEEN SHOULD BE FAVORED.
AGAIN, IN THE FIRST FIVE WEEKS.
THEY HAVE HAD A RELATIVELY EASY
SCHEDULE COMPARED TO SOME OF THE
OTHER TEAMS IN THE LEAGUE.
MEANTIME A TEAM LIKE THE HEAT
ARE IN THE HARDEST SCHEDULE KEEP
YOUR EYE ON THEM THROUGH WEEK
FIVE.
THE LAKERS KEEP MOVING BACK AND
THE NETS STAY PRETTY CONSISTENT
IN TERMS OF THE ODDS DESPITE THE
ABSENCE OF KYRIE IRVING AND I
GET A THEY ARE 13-5 SO
ODDS-MAKERS THINK THEY SHOULD BE
THE PRESEASON FAVORITE AS WELL,
BUT IN THE FIVE LOSSES FOR THE
NETS, THEY HAVE LOST TWO
MILWAUKEE, CHARLOTTE, MIAMI,
CHICAGO AND GOLDEN STATE.
I MEAN, COME ON.
IF THEY PLAY A HARD TEAM THEY
LOSE SO I DO NOT THINK THE
BROOKLYN NETS SHOULD BE THE
FAVORITE ANYMORE.
I DON'T SEE THEM BEING ABLE TO
WIN EVERYTHING WITH KYRIE IRVING
ON THE BENCH.
AS FOR THE WARRIORS, THEY ARE A
TEAM THAT'S BEEN VERY SURPRISING
SO FAR THIS SEASON AND WILL
PROBABLY CONTINUE TO SHOCK US,
AND PLUS THEY WILL GET PLAYERS
BACK.
I DO THINK THE WARRIORS SHOULD
BE FAVORED OR EVEN LESS MONEY AT
THIS POINT
>> YOU MENTIONED THE WARRIORS.
WHEN YOU MENTION THE THE
WARRIORS IN THE LAST SENTENCE IT
JUST MADE ME SMILE
>> YOU SAID IT ALL SEASON.
>> WE'RE GOOD.
>> I'VE BEEN TELLING Y'ALL
BEFORE THE SEASON.
EVERYBODY WAS LIKE OH, THE
WARRIORS, THE WARRIORS, THEY
BARELY MADE THE EIGHTH SEED.
WE GOT SOME KEY ADDITIONS.
GOT IGUODALA, BEATSIA.
OTTO PORTER, GARY PAYTON II.
GOD ADDITION TO THIS TEAM.
THEY ARE LOOKING GOOD, THE
WARRIORS, SITTING AT PLUS 650.
GO AHEAD AND BET IT NOW.
GIVING YOU GUYS WHAT TO DO.
GO BET THE WARRIORS.
>> AND PLAYERS ARE COMING BACK.
I LIKE THAT.
THEY ARE GOING TO GET BETTER
TOWARDS THE SECOND HALF OF THE
SEASON.
>> ERIN, I JUST FORGOT THE MOST
IMPORTANT PART.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT I JUST
FORGOT ME, GREG IVORY, A
WARRIORS FAN FORGOT THE MOST
IMPORTANT PART.
WE'RE GETTING AN OVERALL NUMBER
ONE DRAFT PICK AND KLAY THOMPSON
BACK SO ADD TO THE 15-2 TEAM OF
ALREADY.
THE RICH IS GETTING RICHER IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
IN SAN FRANCISCO THE RICH IS
GETTING RICH AND GOLDEN STATE,
THE WARRIORS SHOULD WIN THE
FINALS.
YOU GUYS PUT THAT BET N.ERIN, I
THINK IT'S TIME TO TALK TO THE
PEOPLE.
LET'S TALK TO THE PEOPLE AND GET
THEIR TAKES.
AVE GO THE INNERMAN, YES, AND
GARY PAYTON, SHOUT-OUT TO YOU,
G. EQUIP, WARRIORS SHOULD BE
NUMBER ONE, THANK YOU.
RICH BART ERNIE ELS IS BACK IN
THE COMMENT SAYING WARRIORS ALL
DAY OF RIGHTEOUS 144.
RIGHTEOUS 144 SAYS PACERS.
RIGHTEOUS 144, YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH A HEED.
EVERYBODY ELSE I SAID THANK YOU
GUYS FOR COMMENTING.
IT'S STILL LOVE.
I THINK YOU GUYS PROBABLY
ALREADY GOT HOODIES BUT
RIGHTEOUS 144, YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH A HEED.
ERIN, I THINK IT'S TIME TO TAKE
THIS THING ON HOME.
TAKE THIS THING ON HOME.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR TAPPING INTO
THE GROUP CHAT PRESENTED BY FAN
DUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
THE THREE BY TWO IS A LOCK EVERY
WEEK AND TAKE AND IT BELIEVE IN
THE SUNSET VIBE.
RUSS OVER IS CASHING IN AT
MADISON SQUARE GARDEN, IN NEW
YORK AND HE'S GOING TO BE ROCKY
THE BABY SO THE OVER IS
CRASHING.
GET ON FAN DUEL AND DELL THE B/R
BETTING SAME GAME PARLAY AND
TUNE INTO THE "INSIDE THE NBA"
PREGAME SHOW.
"INSIDE THE NBA" PREGAME SHOW
WITH CHUCK, SHAQ, KENNY.
CHUCK IS GOING TO BE -- HE'S
GOING TO BE TALKING ABOUT HIS
FAVORITE LEG OF OUR PARLAY, SO
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS TUNA THAT.
WE'LL BE BACK NEXT WEEK GIVING
OUT HOODIES.
GIVING OUT JERSEYS, GIVING OUT
LOCKS.
IF YOU WANTED WON ONE TODAY,
WE'LL DM YOU, NOT ME OR AARON,
BUT B/R BETTING WILL DM YOU.
AND I'M SAD TO SAY THAT ERIN
DOLAN WILL BE LEAVING THE GROUP
CHAT.
UNFORTUNATELY, SHE'S LEAVING THE
GROUP CHAT.
THIS IS HER LAST SHOW SO LET'S
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND DROP
SOME SUNSETS FOR HER.
ERIN, THANK YOU FOR BEING PART
OF THE SQUAD.
>> GROUP CHAT WAS FUN.
>> ERIN, WHY DON'T YOU --
DEFINITELY WAS FUN.
WE HAD FUN HERE IN THE GROUP
CHAT.
ERIN, JUST GET IN THE COMMENTS.
GET IN THE COMMENTS.
>> GET IN THE COMMENTS.
>> JUST GO AHEAD, YEAH.
SCAN THE COMMENTS.
GIVE AWAY A HOODIE.
>> TAKE IT ALL THE WAY HOME AN
TO THE BANK.
HOPEFULLY WE DIDN'T GIVE HIM A
HEED YET.
LOVE THAT.
>> LET'S GIVE HIM ANOTHER ONE.
>> I'M GOING -- SO MANY SUNSETS
COMING THROUGH.
>> EVERYONE IS GETTING A HEED.
EVERYBODY SHE MENTIONED.
>> BLUE 16 HOODIE.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> KEEP ON GOING, ERIN.
>> WEEBZ.
THAT'S AS MUCH AS I CAN GET.
COMING THROUGH QUICK.
APPRECIATE THE SUNSETS.
GREG IVORY WILL DEFINITELY BE
KEEPING THE POSITIVE VIBES HERE
ON THE GROUP CHAT.
>> YES.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING THE GROUP
CHAT.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR RIDING WITH
US.
GET ON FAN DUEL AND RIDE WITH US
ASHES FOLLOW US WITH SOCIAL.
ALONGSIDE ERIN DOLAN I'M GREG
IVORY AND WISHING ALL YOUR
FAMILIES A GREAT THANKSGIVING.
ME AND ERIN, WE'RE LEAVING THE
GROUP CHAT.
PEACE.
>> SEE YA.